[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous j'espère
que vous allez bien j'espère que vous
allez bien bienvenue dans cette émission
spéciale été au programme les
rendez-vous culturels sportifs ou encore
loisirs incontournables à faire cet été
voici les titres de cette édition
spéciale pour les fans de cinéma
l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines vous propose
de redécouvrir des classiques du
septième art sur un écran géant en plein
air pour les plus férus de lecture les
médiathèques de Sky participent à
l'événement partir en livre atelier je
défie vous sont proposés tout au long de
l'été on fait le point dans cette
émission avec notre invité et après la
culture le sport sera également à
l'honneur cet été dans les Yvelines si
vous vous sentez l'âme d'un champion
olympique sachez qu'un village
d'athlétisme va sillonner le nord du
département de nombreuses animations
sportives et ludiques vous attendent
soit à la perche course de vitesse avec
radar ou encore course de haies on en
parle également avec notre invité et
dans cette émission spéciale vous
donneront également nos idées de sortie
à faire cet été dans les Yvelines au
programme un dîner au coeur des animaux
de Thoiry zoo safari un labyrinthe géant
ou encore des activités à Lille de
loisirs de Sky focus également sur la
Fête des Loges notre journaliste Mickel
elle mie d'euro vous fait découvrir les
incontournables de la Fête des Loges à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye et vous étiez avec
lui Gabriel Gauthier bonsoir bonsoir
Mathilde alors c'était comment la Fête
des Loges bah vous allez voir dans
quelques instants on s'est beaucoup
amusé avec Michael il l'a testé pour
vous les activités principales de la
Fête des Loges il s'est beaucoup donné
pour ce reportage et ben on va le
découvrir dans quelques instants avec
nous également en plateau améliobert
bonsoir bonsoir alors vous êtes chargés
de la valorisation des actions
culturelles pour l'agglomération de 50
ans en Yvelines et je le disais à
l'instant dans les titres il y a deux
événements culturels à ne pas manquer
cet été à Sky le ciné en plein air est
parti en livre alors qu'est-ce qu'il
faut attendre de ces deux événements
alors ce sont vraiment des rendez-vous
qui sont à vivre en famille avec les
plus jeunes tous les âges sont sont
représentés ici avec ces événements et
également sinon entre amis puisque le
ciné plein air c'est vraiment aussi à
vivre avec ses amis ses collègues ses
voisins voilà donc on en parlera plus en
détail dans quelques instants à côté de
vous Jean-Philippe Guillots bonsoir
alors vous êtes le président de Grand
Paris seneweez athlétisme et jusqu'au
1er septembre un village d'athlétisme va
sillonner le nord du département
athlétique day ça a commencé hier à
Vaux-sur-Seine aujourd'hui vous étiez à
Magnanville comment est-ce que ça a
démarré cette première édition d'athique
day
déjà enfin beaucoup de jeunes donc on
est sur une sim 6-12 ans à la base mais
de nombreux jeunes notamment sur ces
catégories d'âge et puis on en parlait
un petit peu avant la prise antenne
voilà tout le monde se laisse captiver
un petit peu par cet opération des des
plus jeunes et un peu plus grands enfin
voilà mais tout le monde a envie de
participer donc on en parlera également
plus en détail tout à l'heure et enfin
nous sommes aussi avec un autre
journaliste de la rédaction de TV 78
Grégory canalet bonsoir Maxime bonsoir à
tous vous allez nous présenter les
informations à retenir dans les Yvelines
cet été c'est tout de suite
[Musique]
alors ce soir ce sont des informations
un peu spéciales des informations
spéciales été dans les Yvelines et qui
dit été dit départ en vacances
difficultés sur les routes quand vous
êtes nombreux à vous rendre vers vos
lieux de villégiature un conseil dans la
mesure du possible voyager plutôt la
semaine car c'est bien entendu lors des
weekends que la situation est la plus
tendue certains sont plus propices au
bouchon selon bison Futé a commencé par
le week-end du 14 juillet où ça coince
dès le jeudi 13 dans le sens des départs
en Île-de-France il valait mieux quitter
la région avant midi si vous ne regardez
si vous ne regardez c'est que c'est râpé
et ce n'est pas la journée du 14 juillet
qui est la plus compliquée plutôt celle
du 15 avec des conditions très
difficiles sur tout le territoire
français le dimanche 16 juillet c'est
rouge également en Île-de-France mais
cette fois-ci dans le sens des retours
alors l'été il y a aussi les fameux
chassés croisés entre les juilletistes
et les aoutiens quelles sont les
prévisions qu'ils ont futé sur les
routes Grégory une journée à éviter
celle du Samedi 5 août Bison Futé voie
noir sur l'ensemble du le territoire
dans le sens des départs essayez de
partir le plus tôt possible avant 6h par
exemple après une bonne nuit de sommeil
et d'autres périodes sont également
compliquées comme celle du 15 août qui
tombe cette année un mardi résultat dès
le samedi 12 août trafic très difficile
dans le sens des départs et même orange
pour la région dans le sens des retours
et puis après le repos il faut
malheureusement rentrer au boulot trois
dates ou Bison Futé voire rouge
c'est-à-dire une circulation très
difficile pour les retours les samedis
19 et 26 août plus étonnant le lundi 28
août ou la couleur viro-ci au rouge en
Île-de-France l'école n'aura pas encore
repris puisque la rentrée est fixée pour
cette année aux Quatre Septembre et sur
les routes il est bien évidemment très
important de faire des pauses toutes les
deux heures environ pour ce restaurer
dormir un peu ou pourquoi pas s'évader
quelques instants avec de la lecture
alors si vous prenez l'autoroute A10 par
exemple au départ du péage de
Saint-Arnoult-en-Yvelines vous pourrez
trouver des bibliothèques éphémères sur
vos aires de repos pour la 5e année
consécutive la Fondation VINCI
Autoroutes propose son opération lire
ses voyager ses lire sur 10 aires de son
réseau au total ce sont 25000 livres qui
sont offerts au cours de l'été une
opération menée en partenariat avec la
collection Folio de Gallimard marraine
de l'opération cette année l'écrivaine
Karine tuile et durant cette période
estivale les collectivités vaut aussi en
profiter pour faire des travaux une
trentaine de chantiers se déroulent
pendant l'été dans l'agglomération dans
le détail neuf chantiers de rénovation
de voirie 6 pour étendre ou créer des
pistes cyclables des travaux également
dans les gares à Montigny-le-Bretonneux
elle la verrière ou encore Saint-Quentin
est c'est le nom de la station de cette
ligne 18 la station de la future ligne
18 donc il sera implanté sur la ville de
Guyancourt et puis des chantiers
d'enfouissement des réseaux de
rénovation d'éclairage public espaces
verts ou encore assainissement le détail
est à retrouver sur le site de 50 ans en
Yvelines et le dernier numéro d'ailleurs
de ski mag en vidéo a été consacré à ses
travaux de l'autre côté le département
des Yvelines qui gèrent lui près de 1600
km de route à programmer d'importants
travaux de sécurisation et de
modernisation de son réseau en tout ce
sont 80 chantiers qui sont menés cet été
avec quatre grandes types d'opérations
sécurité routière rénovation des
chaussées aménagement des liaisons
douces et entretien des ouvrages d'art
on écoute ces propos recueillis par
Patrick Jacques de Dixmude il y a
quelques chantiers emblématiques je nous
étions l'an dernier le les travaux du
pont de la deuxième dB Sartrouville
continue c'est un chantier a près de 8
millions d'euros on a un chantier
également assez emblématique
autour de du château sur la commune de
Saint sur la route départementale 7 on
va aménager sur 2,2 km
piste cyclable et on va régénérer la
voie et puis sur le secteur de de
voisins nous avons également un chantier
assez important d'aménagement de
Carrefour pour veiller à la fluidité de
cette axe là c'est un sujet assez
sensible on y était encore la semaine
dernière parce que c'est l'une des
futures voies d'accès à la gare de la
ligne 18 et donc on s'est engagé auprès
des élus locaux et notamment de ma
collègue la mère de voisins d'être aux
côtés de la ville de voisin vous pouvez
consulter l'ensemble de ces travaux
menés par le département des Yvelines
sur le lien qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran vous aurez notamment la
possibilité d'accéder à une carte des
travaux l'été aussi les fortes chaleurs
et parfois même caniculaire vous avez
quelques conseils à nous rappeler
Grégory en premier lieu bien évidemment
s'hydrater alors j'ai pas pris ma petite
bouteille d'eau avec moi en plateau
c'est une erreur mais en tout cas il
faut bien s'hydrater boire entre 1 et 2
litres d'eau par jour privilégié
également les détruisent des légumes
riches en eau comme le melon la pastèque
ou la tomate évitez de sortir aux heures
les plus chaudes de la journée entre 11h
et 17h évite aussi de faire des efforts
physiques alors si vous voulez faire du
sport attendez qu'il fasse un peu plus
frais c'est-à-dire très tôt le matin ou
en début de soirée il faut maintenir
également son logement au frais en
laissant les volets fermés la journée en
ayant le soir ou très tôt le matin et
n'hésitez pas aussi à vous rendre dans
des endroits frais un bon film au cinéma
ça m'a fait mal ça me fait mal à
personne enfin si vous êtes une personne
fragile il vaut mieux vous inscrire au
registre de vigilance de votre commune
pour qu'elle puisse vous appeler et
vérifier régulièrement que vous allez
bien et pour se rafraîchir Grégory on
peut aussi aller faire trempette dans
les piscines et les possibilités sont
nombreuses sur le territoire de 50 ans
en Yvelines cet été à la piscine
intercommunale Salvador Allende aux
Clayes-sous-Bois on peut même prendre
des cours de natation jusqu'au 25 août
on sait que les noyades sont un fléau en
période d'été les inscriptions se font
directement sur place les possibilités
sont nombreuses également au centre
aqualudique de Maurepas avec différents
bassins espace de miendette de bien-être
et de sport large panel d'activités
également au centre aquatique de lac à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux à l'île de
loisirs de 50 ans en Yvelines une aire
de jeux d'eau et ouverte pour les
enfants de moins de 12 ans accompagné
bien évidemment d'un adulte enfin la
piscine municipale de Guyancourt reste
ouverte tous l'été et propose de vous
divertir autour de ces deux bassins d'un
spa sauna et également un solarium et
bien merci beaucoup Grégory canalet pour
toutes ces informations et comme
d'habitude si vous aussi vous voyez une
image ou une information qui vous a
marqué près de chez vous n'hésitez pas à
nous la partager sur les réseaux sociaux
en utilisant le hashtag 78 news
[Musique]
manège a sensation forte très fantôme
borne d'arcade ou encore tir à la
carabine ou encore aller des cuisines je
vous parle bien évidemment de la Fête
des Loges l'une des plus anciennes fêtes
foraines de France revient dans la forêt
de Saint-Germain-en-Laye jusqu'au 20
août notre journaliste Mickael el midoro
était sur place avec Gabriel Gonthier
reportage
[Musique]
elle fête cette année sa 369e édition je
veux bien sûr parler à de la Fête des
Loges implanté ici dans la forêt de
Saint-Jean branlay jusqu'au 20 août
présentation de ce rendez-vous
incontournable dans les Yvelines
[Musique]
alors la Fête des Loges c'est le plus
1138 à l'époque c'est saint Louis qui a
lancé la première Fête des Loges c'est
déjà la plus grande fête foraine de
France à cette époque de l'année l'été
c'est la plus grande il y en a pas il y
en a pas de plus grande et le fait
qu'elle soit dans la forêt avec les
grandes chaleurs tout ça je pense que il
fait il fait souvent plus un peu plus
frais donc ça ça attire pas mal les gens
[Musique]
parmi les incontournables ici à la Fête
des Loges il y a bien sûr les
attractions à sensations fortes le
million de visiteurs qui vient ici
chaque année peut se retrouver à 80
mètres d'altitude et plongé dans le vide
il y a également les chutes du Niagara
ou encore des montagnes russes juste
derrière moi justement il y en a une
Speedy à mouse je vais la tester dans
quelques instants ça a l'air de faire
peur
[Musique]
on
y va c'est un peu sous-estimé cette
attraction c'est quand même assez rapide
mais ça m'a donné envie de continuer ça
commence à tourner
ah oui
en plus en arrière donc ouais c'est
sympa
[Musique]
je pensais que ça durait une minute ça a
duré au moins entre 5 et 7 minutes
j'ai la tête qui tourne mais tout va
bien tout va bien
[Musique]
c'est parti
je suis juste légèrement mouillé
juste un peu
[Musique]
parmi les 170 attractions de la Fête des
Loges il n'y a pas que des attractions à
sensations fortes il y a aussi des
attractions de type familiales comme
cette pêche aux canards c'est
traditionaliste si à la fête foraine je
vais essayer d'empêcher on va voir ce
que ça donne
un bleu pour la route je vais tester les
autres attractions familiales il y en a
beaucoup
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon bah il n'y a pas que les attractions
ici à la Fête des Loges il y a aussi la
nourriture qui prend une grande place
ici dans cette fête foraine moi je suis
un gros gourmand et je vais commencer à
m'asseoir avec des churros il y en a une
douzaine je crois dans le paquet
ils ont l'air très bon
[Musique]
après un bon goûter au niveau du stand
de déchuros nous sommes dans l'allée des
cuisines nous allons passer à
l'incontournable de l'incontournable ici
juste derrière moi c'est chez Milo on va
bien manger il y a du jarret il y a du
porcelet il y a vraiment de tout j'ai
hâte de découvrir tout ça
[Musique]
merci
à la spécialité chez Milo c'est le
jarret il y a également le porcelet
j'adore ça je le prends tous les ans
mais cette année j'ai décidé de prendre
un mix grill et je vais poser du coup la
viande sur cette pierre chaude
ça cuise ça va être excellent j'en suis
sûr
[Musique]
voici donc les incontournables de la
Fête des Loges la Fête des Loges c'est
jusqu'au 20 août ici dans la forêt à de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye moi je vais
continuer un petit peu ma visite et
faire quelques attractions
voilà on voit que Michael el midoro a
bien profité de la
370e édition de cette Fête des Loges
est-ce que vous êtes déjà rendu à la
Fête des Loges autour de ce plateau oui
vous êtes d'accord avec ces
incontournables vous avez déjà testé
incroyables donc c'est génial
Jean-Philippe Guillot vous avez
également pu tester pas récemment mais
sur ce que j'ai vu je pense que je
passerai peut-être un peu plus de sens
ça vous a donné envie d'y retourner
et vous Grégory cananet Gabriel Gontier
alors pour moi c'était la première fois
et très bonne expérience et puis c'est
ce qui ressort vraiment je trouve c'est
la convivialité du lieu il y a des
familles qui sont là depuis des
générations et dans les visiteurs aussi
il y en a qui viennent depuis des années
enfants et qui maintenant viennent avec
leurs enfants c'est assez impressionnant
vous voyez on fait un métier difficile à
tester des attractions à la Fête des
Loges on teste aussi les les mecs
parce que c'était son petit défi de
faire cette attraction la boule lancée
sur deux élastiques donc bah il est y
arriver donc bravo à lui bravo à lui on
sait qu'il est pas très fan des manèges
à sensation forte et notamment de cette
boule alors cet été l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines vous propose
également des rendez-vous culturels
incontournables pour en parler avec nous
Amélie Aubert chargé de la valorisation
des actions culturelles à Sky au
programme du coup des séances de cinéma
en plein air à la coulée verte
d'Élancourt quels sont les films que
vous allez proposer alors on va proposer
des films tous les jeudis soir
rendez-vous réguliers des films pour les
tout-petits des films pour les plus
grands comme je disais tout à l'heure on
va commencer la première séance Jeudi
prochain avec le dessin animé dragon
cette fameuse histoire du jeune viking
qui va saluer d'amitié avec un dragon et
qui va du coup un peu rendre mal sa
communauté de vikings j'en dis pas plus
on va poursuivre le jeudi suivant le 27
juillet avec un cas sable on en parle
quasiment plus plus sérieux très connu
également je pense Bruce Willis Samuel
et Jackson autour de cette maladie des
autres vers voilà j'en dis pas plus
parce que ce serait spoiler le film au
mois d'août on démarre le jeudi 3 août
avec ténor ça c'est un film français
avec Michel Laroque plutôt comédie
l'histoire de ce jeune slamer qui se
retrouve aussi livreur et il va livrer à
l'Opéra Garnier et là on va découvrir
des dons insoupçonnés le jeudi suivant
le 10 août là on est plutôt sur un film
musical comédie musicale yesterday là
encore un musicien peu connu qui
malheureusement va avoir un accident de
bus et qui a son réveil se rend compte
que personne ne connaît les Beatles
l'avant dernier film sera tous en scène
tous en scène alors là on est sur un
dessin animé très grand public familial
très humoristique là c'est l'histoire
d'un koala qui veut sauver son théâtre
coûte que coûte et qui qui cherche un
moyen pour pour éviter la fermeture et
va participer à un concours de chant
avec cinq candidats les complètement
usques voilà donc très drôle là aussi
avec de l'humour autant pour les adultes
que pour les enfants donc il y en a
vraiment pour tout le monde et on va
clôturer le cinéma de plein air avec un
film plus emblématique la couleur de la
victoire un peu plus sérieux le film de
Stephen Hopkins où là on va plus faire
référence à Jessy Owens l'athlète multi
médaillée des années 30 et qui se
prépare aux Jeux Olympiques de Berlin
pour 1936 dans un jeux olympiques de
Paris
politique et historique qu'on connaît et
effectivement voulait terminer clôturer
par ce film des JO un petit clin d'oeil
à l'année prochaine puisque 51 Yvelines
va accueillir sur quatre sites
olympiques les Jeux Olympiques
quatre sites olympiques dont la colline
d'Élancourt le vélo Drôme le golf
national et le Stadium de BMX ça va se
passer l'été prochain autour donc des
disciplines de golf de vélo de VTT de
BMX
j'avais juste une question parce que ces
opérations reposent bien sûr aussi sur
le beau temps est-ce qu'il y a des
solutions de repli dans le cas où il y a
des soirées où il pleut par exemple
vous dire que malheureusement non voilà
on peut être amené à annuler vraiment en
cas de forte pluie bien évidemment ce
serait quand même très désagréable
surtout que les conditions de projection
sont quand même assez incroyables on a
un écran de 15 mètres de diamètre sur un
site emblématique comme vous l'avez dit
à la Commanderie donc ouais on va
croiser les doigts très fort voilà on
espère d'avoir le même temps que le mois
de juin mais voilà il se peut que on
annule en dernier minute il faut aussi
attendre de son donner toujours les
informations sur le site de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines ou sur les
réseaux sociaux et puis pareil pour les
horaires on annonce toujours les
horaires au mois de juillet plutôt à
partir de 22h au mois d'août à partir de
21h on peut des fois décaler d'un quart
d'heure en fonction de la luminosité
c'est vrai que début aoûtes et fin août
voilà le soleil se couche plutôt donc on
est peu être amené à faire des
délancements de projection un peu plus
tard alors il y a des films pour les
plus jeunes des films un peu plus
sérieux de la comédie également je vous
propose de regarder quelques extraits et
on continue d'en parler juste après
c'est mon grand vas-y mon grand
pourquoi vous me regardez comme ça
je regarde comme ça pour deux raisons
la première c'est parce qu'apparemment
vous êtes le seul survivant de cette
accident
et la deuxième
c'est parce que vous n'avez aucune
gratitude
merde
la personne qui a effectué cette
livraison ça vous dirait un petit
exercice de chant c'est quoi
l'embrouille en fait
[Musique]
quand est-ce que tu as écrit ça c'est
pas moi c'est pas le McCartney qui a
écrit ça les Beatles
qui écrivez les chansons oui mais
vraiment je sais pas chaque habitant de
cette ville a une chance de devenir une
star dans monter à
[Musique]
nous devons boycotter les Jeux
Olympiques sous le régime d'Hitler
pour démontrer notre solidarité avec des
peuples primés d'Allemagne
alors on vient de le voir il y en a pour
tous les goûts au final ce sont vraiment
des films grand public est-ce que vous
avez des préférences autour de ce
plateau pour rester dans le thème des JO
peut-être le dernier la couleur de la
victoire c'est d'actualité pareil
Grégory bah oui alors après moi je suis
fan de tous les tous les films même un
Tous en scène me plaît bien mais c'est
vrai que la couleur de la victoire ça
fait référence un épisode histoire qui
moi me parle en tant que passionné de
sport Jessie Wayne ce qui avait fait
face à l'époque à Hitler qui avait gagné
du coup des médailles face à face à
Hitler et donc ça c'est vrai un vrai
épisode de l'histoire qui me parle à moi
en tant que passionné de sport et vous
Jean-Philippe Guillot est-ce que vous
avez une préférence parmi ces dessins
animés et la couleur de la victoire
également et puis la petite anecdote
c'est que notamment sur cette épreuve
donc le concours de son longueur Jesse
Wayne a été en train de perdre un petit
peu voilà il était pas au mieux dans son
concours et c'est son adversaire
allemand qui l'accompagne qui l'aide
notamment avec lancé marques et puis
après avec les résultats voilà qui sont
déroulés donc c'est
très bonne anecdote et vous aussi
un médecin
qui m'avait tellement marqué à l'époque
de sa sortie avec Bruce Willis enfin le
duo Samuel Jackson c'était
marquant alors il est aussi un autre
événement culturel à cet été à ne pas
manquer ce sont les médiathèques de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines qui
participent à l'action nationale partir
en livre jusqu'au 1er septembre le thème
de cette année c'est la liberté avec une
héroïne mortelle Adèle quelles sont les
animations qui sont prévues autour
d'elle alors il y en a énormément
puisque cette année l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et le réseau
des médiathèques a décidé de travailler
avec en collaboration avec toutes les
communes donc il y a des animations qui
sont plus pour les tout-petits un
spectacle qui s'appelle le swing des
tout-petits on va apprendre à compter à
danser voilà pour les plus jeunes on va
avoir des ateliers plus de fabrication
de coloriage une sensibilisation si à
l'environnement avec Hector la remorque
pour apprendre un peu la vie qu'il y a
aussi dans les arbres on va avoir des
rallies nature avec l'association ville
verte et puis il va y avoir un grand
temps fort enfin partir en livre qui est
cette fameuse collaboration pour créer
une œuvre collective on va inviter les
habitants à venir
sur des ateliers de création avec deux
intervenants
Élise Robin qui est donc dessinatrice
illustratrice et puis Laurent azuelo qui
est compteur et botaniste donc un duo
qui va voilà proposer aux habitants de
créer cette œuvre collective autour de
votre arbre frères il faut savoir que
chacun de nous a un symbole arbre en
fonction de son mois de naissance et
toutes ces œuvres qui vont être créées
tout au long de l'été avec les habitants
seront ensuite restitués à la
médiathèque Jean rouslou au mois de
septembre sous forme d'exposition et
puis dans les autres médiathèques et un
temps fort le 30 septembre pour ce
vernissage ce lancement en fait et cette
découverte de toutes les œuvres qui ont
été faites par les habitants
ou la miniature le bibliobus qui va
sillonner un petit peu toutes les
communes de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
qui va être au plus près des plus jeunes
pourquoi c'est important de faire sortir
les livres de la bibliothèque alors
c'est justement donner l'occasion aux
habitants de d'approcher les livres de
pouvoir lire dans des conditions qui
sont assez inattendu ça peut être autant
sur un transat dans un parc où les
sous-bois dans n'importe quelle ville
donc voilà l'idée c'était vraiment
d'apporter le livre auprès des habitants
et de les éviter voilà de devoir venir
dans les médiathèques même si les
médiathèques restent toujours ouvertes
alors il y a quelques fermetures mais il
y aura toujours une médiathèque ouverte
près de chez vous et du coup là le
bibliobus voilà permet d'accéder de
donner accès à la littérature au plus
jeune à travers différentes animations
également sur toute le territoire ils
sont toujours attirés par la lecture les
plus jeunes selon vous alors ça va
dépendre du type de littérature et de
livres que l'on propose d'un manga un
livre de contes que ce soit des livres
de science-fiction voilà on va pouvoir
toucher différents publics différents
âges mais oui heureusement le livre est
toujours présent en route exactement ça
parle forcément ça exactement alors il y
a aussi un autre rendez-vous un peu plus
éloigné de la lecture c'est du beatbox
du slam beatbox où les jeunes ils vont
pouvoir réciter
des textes sur la liberté exactement on
a tôt qui est l'interprète qui va venir
et qui va montrer ce qu'est
effectivement le slam et le beatbox donc
quand même donc là on est plus sur un
public ado ça se présente sous forme
d'atelier on montre ce que c'est les
jeunes ensemble vont constituer un petit
groupe vont préparer des écritures et il
y a un petit temps de restitution
ensuite à la fin pour pour le public
effectivement bien merci beaucoup Amélie
Aubert d'avoir accepté notre invitation
en plateau alors pour rappel partir en
livre c'est jusqu'au 1er septembre dans
toutes les médiathèques de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines vous
retrouverez toutes les informations sur
le site Internet qui s'affiche sur votre
écran et le cinéma en plein air c'est du
20 juillet au 24 août à la coulée verte
d'Élancourt vous retrouverez également
toutes les informations pratiques sur le
site internet qui s'affiche en bas de
votre écran et les Yvelines regorgent
d'activités culturelles de la nature en
passant par l'art contemporain réginera
lèche vous a concocté concocté son top 3
des ex positions à ne pas rater dans les
Yvelines cet été
[Musique]
voilà pour ce top 3 des expositions à
faire dans les Yvelines cet été mais il
n'y a pas que de la culture cet été dans
les Yvelines pour ceux qui ont plus
l'âme d'un sportif un village
d'athlétisme va sillonner le nord du
département tous l'été jusqu'au 1er
septembre il s'agit d'athlétique day
pour en parler avec nous Jean-Philippe
Guillot le président de Grand Paris
seneweez athlétisme alors première
question quelles sont les épreuves
sportives enfin les petits jeux sportifs
qu'on va pouvoir retrouver
on va retrouver différentes disciplines
de l'athlétisme notamment le saut à la
perche le saut en longueur
des petits ateliers de motricité de
bondissement tout ce qui va être lancé
de force dans cette précision des
courses de haies et la course de vitesse
avec notamment des radars ou tout le
monde a envie de courir le record du
copain ou de la copine donc un grand
panel d'activité autour de l'athlétisme
il s'agit d'une première édition
pourquoi est-ce que vous avez décidé de
lancer cette première édition et surtout
de sillonner le nord du département on
l'avait déjà testé en vire dans le cadre
d'opération locale et puis après le but
fin nous notre volonté c'est vraiment
d'être acteurs de notre territoire
GPSO athlétisme c'est une entente
sportive club d'athlétisme qui regroupe
8 autres sections sportives des clubs
qui vont de Mantes-la-Jolie à Coignières
Limay Les Mureaux melons Poissy Conflans
Vernouillet donc ça c'est un territoire
vaste et on avait un petit peu comme
comme ambition justement d'animer ce
territoire notamment d'où l'idée de
cette tournée 1960
l'objectif du coup c'est d'apporter le
sport au plus près des communes au plus
près des jeunes oui c'est vraiment de
partager notre passion faire découvrir
l'athlétisme un plus grand nombre bon là
effectivement on s'est plutôt au départ
une cible on va dire un petit peu plus
6-12 ans mais on voit que une fois qu'on
est là qu'on arrive dans une ville et
qu'on se pose comme vous avez pu le
constater qu'on soit les plus jeunes ou
qu'on soit même un peu plus voilà un
petit peu plus avancé dans son âge tout
le monde a envie un petit peu de ce
tester un petit peu de pas avoir mis des
baskets hier matin pour pouvoir tester
la course avec la course vitesse avec
des radars Gabriel justement dans les
profils que vous avez est-ce que c'est
des jeunes qui ont déjà pratiqué de
l'athlétisme à l'école par exemple où
ils découvrent complètement on a on a
vraiment tout tous les profils on a des
jeunes qui découvrent vraiment
l'athlétisme on a des jeunes qui faut
savoir qu'on accueille il y a un travail
de préparation dès qu'on arrive dans une
ville bien sûr on se rapproche notamment
des acteurs locaux
on dès qu'on a la possibilité on laisse
on fait passer des structures notamment
les centres des espaces de quartier des
secteurs jeunesse et après bien sûr la
partie libre donc en général quand on
passe par des structures oui les enfants
font bien sûr ont abordé l'athlétisme à
l'école ou dans un autre cadre mais
c'est une manière différente de
découvrir l'activité c'est ce qui est
intéressant et
par exemple sur un atelier qui est
l'atelier longueur c'est un escalier
tout simplement avec des marches avec
des codes couleurs les chercher et pour
réussir les chercher ces marches plus
haut possible et ben les jeunes s'en
rendre compte pour faire un geste qui
reste très technique qui est dans le
saut en longueur ce qu'on appelle la
technique du ramener pour aller chercher
le sable le plus loin possible et par
l'aménagement de cet espace les enfants
arrivent à faire ce geste technique qui
leur procure énormément de sensations
dès qu'on est dans l'aérien voilà on
vole et c'est un petit peu ça donc les
enfants passent un quart d'heure à peu
près par Atelier découvre ça et partent
avec la banane
qui vous disent qui vont continuer
l'athlétisme s'inscrire oui puis c'est
un temps d'échange avec les avec les
familles aussi les familles viennent
nous voir à la fin
regagnent la petite médaille à l'arrivée
donc son courage mais on voit à travers
ses disciplines on retrouve un petit peu
de tout le dépassement de soi la
confiance en soi beaucoup certains sur
le sol à perche au départ on est sur un
ce qu'on appelle un son en contrebas
donc et ben oui ça c'est pas le si leur
premier petit saut dans le vide il faut
passer par cette étape et puis après ben
on y arrive c'est bizarre
c'est l'occasion aussi pour vous de
repérer des futurs talents ou des
adhérents j'ai pas forcément le but
premier après bien sûr on sait
dans cette société actuelle
des fois on reste plus souvent plus
facilement peut-être devant un écran que
elle allait faire de la culture ou du
sport et c'est vrai que personnellement
je préférais voir les gens faire de la
culture enfin voir les gens faire de la
Culture et du Sport donc on voit des
jeunes avec énormément de qualité
que ça soit dans des villes rurales ou
des grandes villes ou même au cœur de
nos quartiers je suis sûr qu'il y a un
Jesse un Jesse Owens quelque part
Usain Bolt ou du Plantis
de s'évader de se vider l'esprit c'est
aussi il y a beaucoup de bienfaits dans
le sport oui oui alors c'est vrai que à
travers cette étape alors on essaye
aussi c'est de au-delà du bienfait de
sportif c'est amener une culture un
petit peu plus large au-delà du sport et
c'est pour ça qu'on travaille aussi sur
un expos sur les Jeux Olympiques et à
travers notamment
les panneaux d'expo mais c'est encore le
cas cet après-midi sur sur Magnanville
c'est un temps d'échange et de partage
avec avec les jeunes notamment d'un
point de vue historique sur des faits
marquants on parlait de tout à l'heure
le la petite anecdote sur Jessie Owens
voilà il y a plein de choses comme ça
qui des défaits marquants qui nous
permettent d'échanger avec les jeunes
autour de ça on le voit à l'écran en
fait
de manière chronologique le début des
Jeux Olympiques c'était en 1896 à
Athènes jusqu'à aujourd'hui Paris 2024
et donc en fait vous vous faites un
exposé devant les jeunes comment ça se
passe ou c'est eux qui vont pour
découvrir on intègre l'exposition comme
donc quand les jeunes rendent en
dispositif notamment dans le village ils
ont à peu près deux heures d'activité
entre deux heures et 2h15 activités et
l'exposition intégrée au même titre que
n'importe quel autre atelier
donc c'est au moins un quart d'heure
d'échange autour de cette exposition et
des différentes thématiques où les
valeurs que l'exposition véhicule
notamment et il se rendent compte de ce
que représente les Jeux Olympiques
puisque la dernière fois qui en a eu en
France en 1924 le fait que c'est
peut-être une seule fois dans une vie
qu'on va vivre des Jeux Olympiques sur
sur le territoire et ce qui sont au fait
de ça ou justement il faut il faut les
sensibiliser les informer sur sur le
sujet il faut parfois les sensibiliser
là où ils sont plus sensibles c'est
peut-être sur sur l'évolution des
enfin du matériel notamment même sur les
revêtements sur les tenues quand
lorsqu'on voit l'équipe de foot en 19
voilà c'est pas voilà les maillots sont
conçus de la même manière le ballon de
foot ou même le revêtement d'une piste
synthétique avant c'était voilà la
cendrée et c'est le voit sur les visuels
donc c'est vrai que ça interprète et
puis après pareil
notamment sur une des expos c'était 1924
Johnny weissmüller donc bon on s'amuse
voilà sur la photo montrez-moi le
sportif qui aussi une deuxième carrière
notamment un acteur célèbre et puis du
coup alors des fois il le découvre des
fois par chance des fois et puis après
encore une fois on échange autour de ça
et bien merci beaucoup
Guillaume d'avoir accepté notre
invitation pour rappel le village
d'athlétisme d'athlétique Dave sillonner
tout le nord du département cet été
jusqu'au 1er septembre vous avez la
liste des villes qui s'affichent sur
votre écran de télévision pour connaître
les dates et les lieux sinon vous pouvez
vous rendre sur le site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de votre écran pour
avoir toutes les informations pratiques
et toujours en sport du cyclisme du
football ou encore du baseball notre
journaliste sportif Michaël ennemie Doro
vous alistez les événements à ne pas
manquer cet été dans les Yvelines
[Musique]
alors est-ce qu'il y a un événement que
vous attendez le plus avec impatience
sur le territoire cet été le Tour de
France forcément la l'Ultimate bon
malheureusement je pense que le duel
entre pogaccha et vingtgart aura déjà
donné son hacker ce que c'est pas sur la
dernière étape que se joue un tour de
France mais forcément d'avoir cet
événement au plus proche il y a quelques
mois plus des Jeux Olympiques forcément
c'est un événement qui ne sera pas vous
choisissez pas le foot Grégory ça
m'étonnes
on aura l'occasion de parler de
Versailles un peu plus tard mais là sur
ce mois de juillet il y a le Tour de
France qui va arriver Gabriel une
préférence pareil je suis pas une grande
spécialiste mais quand même le Tour de
France ça rassemble un peu tout le monde
et puis c'est juste à côté de chez nous
avec l'ambiance la caravane qui passe
juste avant c'est vrai que c'est un
événement incontournable améliorer
Jean-Philippe Guillot ce serait
peut-être le Paris-Brest-Paris pour
l'avoir connu quelques années c'est vrai
que c'est un événement où on voit des
Japonais des Néo-Zélandais des voilà des
gens qui viennent de pays qui
connaissent le Paris-Brest-Paris et qui
viennent spécifiquement faire cette
course là du coup c'est assez incroyable
alors cet été les communes Yvelines
organisent également leur événement
estival après dis-moi de travaux la
ville de Trappes a inauguré samedi
dernier son nouvel espace extérieur le
complexe sportif Jacques Moncaut baptisé
la plage il est dédié aux familles et
ouvert jusqu'au 19 août l'accès est
gratuit pour tous les Trappistes un
reportage de Patrick Jacques de dismude
et Janelle Martin
[Musique]
un toboggan flambant neuf une piscine ou
encore un terrain de beach-volley au
complexe sportif Jacques Monod trappes
tout est prêt pour l'ouverture de la
plage ces jeunes visiteurs découvrent
les nouvelles installations
[Musique]
après 10 mois de travaux la ville
propose ce samedi un nouvel espace de
détente dédié aux familles 3,4 millions
d'euros ont été déboursés par la
municipalité pour construire jeux
aquatiques aire de détente et autres
cabines de plage 8 juillet au 16 août
sans interruption avec des nocturnes des
soirées spéciales des loto des grandes
dictées géantes etc on donne du bonheur
à toutes les générations des plus âgées
au plus petit et comme vous le voyez le
site a été pensé pour donner sa place à
chacun un air de vacances
particulièrement apprécié par la
centaine d'enfants et de parents ven
nombreux ce jour là on avait hâte que ça
ouvre et on est super fier de ce parc
aquatique c'est la détente voilà début
des vacances on va poursuivre ça tous
l'été
en vacances et proprement et parce qu'on
est bons vacances ici même il y a des
endroits en vacances entrefaces et ça
fait plaisir c'est bien ça plaît à tout
le monde au moins tous les tout le monde
peut jouer il y a beaucoup d'espace
c'est trop bien ça m'a fait plaisir de
venir ici tous les ans on y viendra le
plus possible la plage est ouverte du 8
juillet au 19 août au complexe sportif
Jacques monco de Trappes l'événement est
gratuit pour tous les trappistes
[Musique]
et Gabriel comme chaque semaine on vous
retrouve pour vos idées de sortie cette
fois-ci pas du week-end mais de l'été et
après trap plage c'est Guyancourt qui
propose également son événement estival
et oui Mathilde avec l'événement vive
l'été la ville prend des airs de station
de vacances avec de nombreuses activités
au programme soirée festival avec grand
barbecue et musique atelier de création
vous pourrez notamment créer avec de
l'osier ou encore participer à un
atelier culinaire pour réaliser un
sorbet des sorties sont également
proposées aux zoo refuge la tanière ou
encore au cirque je vous conseille
notamment de vous rapprocher de vos
communes respectives car elle propose de
nombreuses activités pendant l'été et
parmi les communes qui proposent des
activités certaines font partie de
l'opération les Yvelines font leur
cinéma qui débute en août oui qui débute
en août l'événement revient pour sa
douzième édition organisée par le
département des Yvelines 68 projections
estivales sont proposées cette année
l'objectif proposé une programmation
variée et familiale et apporter le
cinéma dans les communes rurales et les
quartiers prioritaires parmi les
projections des classiques Maman j'ai
raté l'avion Top Gun rasta Rocket ou
encore Belle et Sébastien chaque séance
est gratuite et en plein air avec des
transats installés spécialement pour
l'occasion vous aurez également la
possibilité de pique-niquer et de
profiter des food truck avant la
projection vous avez un autre événement
estival et insolite à nous proposer
Gabriel oui surtout gourmand Mathilde
lédiner aux eaux safari de Thoiry
revienne pour la saison estivale et
jusqu'au 9 septembre vous pourrez
profiter d'un dîner en plein coeur de la
savane africaine sous le regard des
zèbres des antilopes et même des
éléphants avec cette expérience
culinaire hors norme hors norme une
balade en camion brousse de 45 minutes
vous sera proposé avant de rejoindre
l'espace dédié au dîner cette expérience
unique à tout de même un coup comptez 85
euros par personne pour le repas alors
on quitte la savane et on prend la
direction de Jouars Pontchartrain avec
avec son pop-corn labyrinthe oui depuis
le 8 juillet le pop-corn labyrinthe de
Jouars Pontchartrain à renverse ses
portes ou plutôt son champ de maïs au
public sur près de quatre hectares vous
pourrez venir vous défier dans le
labyrinthe géant tout au long du
parcours des jeux de piste et des jeux
en bois vous seront proposés de quoi
doublement vous défier en famille ou
entre amis pour les plus téméraires des
sections des sessions pardon nocturnes
seront propres proposées les vendredis
de juillet et on termine avec une sortie
un peu plus rafraîchissante c'est à
l'île de loisirs de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines oui on l'a
présente plus incontournable dans les
Yvelines la base de loisirs est ouverte
tous les jours en accès libre et pour
toutes les tranches d'âge sur la base de
loisirs les activités sont variées golf
centre équestre canoë-kayak ou encore
jeux d'eau tout ça dans un cadre naturel
au milieu de la nature et c'est aussi
dans ce cadre que le théâtre s'invite à
l'île de loisirs de Sky avec le retour
de l'opération l'Île-de-France fête le
théâtre oui pour ça septième édition
l'opération l'Île-de-France faite le
théâtre se déploie cette fois dans 4
îles de loisirs de la région parmi elles
celle de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines du 19
au 24 août seront proposés des
représentations théâtrales mais aussi
des ateliers d'initiation Allard et du
hip-hop si tous les spectacles et les
activités sont gratuites pensez à vous
inscrire sur le site île-de-france.fr
qui s'affiche en bas de votre écran et
bien merci beaucoup Gabriel Gauthier
pour toutes ces idées de sorties est-ce
que vous avez une petite préférence
parmi votre sélection le dîner aux
autres safari ne m'intéresserait bien
oui mais ça a l'air très bon et autour
de ce plateau une préférence le film Top
Gun
une série de cinéma Jean-Philippe
Guillaume Top Gun également et vous
Grégory
labyrinthe et en plus la formule
nocturne je crois qui est en mode murder
party ou Aurore enfin nuit de l'horreur
avec des
zombies qui vous poursuivent ça peut
être pas mal pour une sortie originale
cet été tout à fait c'est vrai que c'est
tentant également je vous propose
maintenant de prendre un peu de hauteur
direction l'Espace Rambouillet jusqu'à
la fin des vacances de la Toussaint vous
pouvez tester des trampolines géant
suspendus aux arbres une expérience à la
fois ludique et sportive qui est incluse
dans le billet d'entrée on écoute
Anthony Raymond responsable pédagogique
de l'Espace Rambouillet au micro de
Céline Charles
[Musique]
ça s'appelle la forêt des milles
l'écureuils c'est ce qu'on appelle un
parc à bout donc c'est une surface de
plus de 1000 m² c'est inspiré de fil
catamaran pour partir c'est défilé
tendus et du coup qui donne un effet
très rebondissant 8 modules des
passerelles voilà qui permettent
d'accéder à différents modules et
ensuite il y a deux sorties par les
toboggans ou alors pour ceux qui sont
pas trop téméraires ils peuvent repartir
par là où ils sont rentrés
[Musique]
c'est une structure qui s'adresse à tout
public donc à partir du moment où on a 4
ans on peut y aller accompagner des
adultes c'est familial l'objectif de
partager des souvenirs ensemble
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ils aiment c'est pouvoir monter déjà
c'est sympa de grimper de se retrouver à
une certaine hauteur en toute sécurité
et à ce côté bondissant qui qui plaît
beaucoup c'est sûr on perd un peu
l'équilibre on a envie de s'élever un
petit peu donc il y a une petite perte
de repères dans un premier temps puis
après on se prête au jeu et puis on a
envie d'avoir des sensations tout
simplement
est-ce qu'on voulait nous c'était mettre
en valeur la forêt et c'est vrai que ce
sentiment se rapprocher au plus proche
de l'arbre de grimper voilà en quelque
sorte à l'intérieur il y a plein de
panneaux des petits supports
pédagogiques qui parlent des arbres des
animaux qui peuplent la forêt donc c'est
aussi une manière sensibiliser à ce
sujet là
[Musique]
et c'est bientôt la fin de cette
émission mais juste avant de se quitter
je vous propose de regarder le dernier
numéro de cette saison dès lors quoi de
beau Thomas Fletcher et Patrick Jacques
de Dixmude était également à la Fête des
Loges ils ont testé plusieurs stands et
ont notamment rencontré Daniel le roi de
la pièce regardez
alors quoi de beau
alors
c'est bon on y va
[Musique]
la pêche
comment on gagne chez vous là chez moi
on gagne à tous les coups
il y a 250
ah oui oui il peut tout tirer en une
fois et il peut pas tirer 33 ficelles
de tirer 40 ficelles d'un coup
les gens ils tombent et tu m'as ni la
tronçonneuse aussi ou pas
on est d'accord ouais le plus c'est
juste une surprend les gens alors que
moi les gens ils me voient
ils ont peur faudra lui dire au clown il
y a pas de souci je vais lui faire une
formation comment tu vas choisir
une peluche donc vous gagnez à tous les
coups chez moi c'est marqué il y a
jamais de perdant
pas jouer on a gagné moi je vais tirer
le gros nounours rose attends attends
attends attends attends attends attends
vous avez un ciseau
[Musique]
madame my innocente
un poisson
yes on a gagné merci
de rien vous voulez jouer parce qu'il
vienne de l'installer là je pense le
directeur
le roi de la pièce
merci Chef et il a pris ses pièces hein
[Rires]
bombarder OK
[Musique]
on a le droit de mettre des coups de
pied dans le truc pas moi
ok
[Musique]
tu as rien d'autre à faire de ta journée
toi parce que là vous vous amusez là
on peut lui demander pour celle-là aussi
on lui dit qu'on a beaucoup joué sur
celle-là ok quoi Go Go et là tu triches
encore là
allez
[Musique]
c'est bon tricher sans tricher ça ça va
rien alors un truc c'est la vie oh là là
[Musique]
c'est des liasse quoi c'est des liasses
viens on se casse en courant rien de
comment les riches regarde comment les
riches dure pas mal 25 pièces on sait
jamais on sait jamais si ça se trouve on
est à 25 pièces
allez là encore gagné encore gagné vous
changez de côté c'est une technique ça
c'est une technique la deuxième mi-temps
alors les joueurs les joueurs allez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et vous êtes capable de partir en
vacances ensemble après quoi allez-vous
triste
ainsi on peut pas taper
là il triche là là il triche il les
avance ou il recule là il fait quoi là
allez là
calme
après comme on est riche il y a plein de
moments il faut qu'on s'arrête aussi
parce que apparemment ça ferme à une
heure
allez
c'est fatiguant je vais avoir des
courbatures moi ça c'est une technique
aussi c'est la jambe là
pas de compte
il m'a fait peur car il a souffert
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire de tous cet
argent Daniel boulot j'ai mal au coude
la météo là donc le soleil mais bon
alors
et c'est la fin de cette édition
spéciale été merci pour votre fidélité
je vous souhaite une belle soirée sur TV
78 un bel été et de bonnes vacances mais
surtout prenez soin de vous
[Musique]